[Musica]
[Applauso]
spero che il mio contributo possa
aiutare i tanti a difendere un nuovo
meraviglioso luogo delle meraviglie la
scuola io ci sto provando
non devo raccontare quello che ho
vissuto io posso dirvi che non dobbiamo
perdere altri minuti preziosi per
garantire e per preservare l'umanità e
io dico che tutto questo lo devo fare
anche per dare chance ai miei ragazzi
arrivo 13 anni fa al parco verde di
caivano in qualità di dirigente
scolastica in quanto aveva visto avevo
vinto il concorso venivo già forte da
un'esperienza particolare alle tavole
realta difficili a godere della bellezza
della scuola e arrivare lì da dirigente
per me fu una gioia incredibile ma fu
anche una gioia perché chi prima di me
nascesse quella scuola
io dico che il mio primo incarico una
scuola del primo ciclo bambini dalla
scuola dell'infanzia alla scuola media
la scuola primaria prima della scuola
media e li ho dato veramente tutta me
stessa
certo quando arrivai vedere materassi
incrociare qualche pistola nel giardino
avere tanta incuria e non trovare un
banco pulito
mi fece quasi pensare che non sarebbe
stato possibile immaginare quella scuola
che io ho tanto amato da ragazza e
l'aveva immaginata sempre bella per gli
altri mi è bastato poco poco il silenzio
e l'indifferenza dell'altro stato e
l'indifferenza del mio stato a darmi una
forza incredibile ho lavorato per lui
per nove lunghi anni non ho conosciuto
basta eppure l'unica cosa che mi ha
aiutata in quel momento in quel periodo
e la lucidità a far vedere agli altri
della bellezza della cultura difficile
era convincere e trascinare gli altri a
non scegliere quel luogo come luogo di
lavoro ma come luogo di prodi dono come
luogo di apprendimento
bastarono i primi due tre giorni capì
subito che io non dovevo andare ad
insegnare o a dire cosa fare
capì subito che io dovevo soltanto fare
e l'apprendimento più importante che ho
ricevuto da loro e il sorriso
malgrado tutto in due o tre anni sono
riuscita a pulire la scuola ad ordinarla
perché era bella già perché chi incrocia
la scuola dello stato e jean è già a
casa
tu non devi fare altro che nutrirla con
i valori con la conoscenza e con le
competenze e passarono i primi sei sette
mesi
tutti mi guardavano un po cosa vuole
fare dove vuole arrivare
e quando arriva il momento della scelta
del mio stato
qualcuno ha detto bisogna trovare un
equilibrio non tutto si può fare
quella parola non tutto si può fare
mi ha accompagnata per tutto quel 3 be
mi accompagno ancora oggi poi nel
silenzio quando tutto sembrava dare una
luce passare dal 41 per cento della
dispersione scolastica al 20 per cento
per me era una gratificazione
incredibile ma anche lasciare un solo
ragazza a casa nell'indifferenza mi
faceva male
volevo di più volevo trasformare la
scuola in una verticalizzazione da
bambino a grande io ci sono per te per
aiutarti ecco questo era il senso tutti
quanti fecero scudo
alla mia proposta tutti ebbero paura di
avere una nuova edizione della scuola
ed ecco che gli dissero devi stare zitto
mi aiutarlo con grande gentilezza a
cambiare aria
fui fortunata perché mi trasferire in
una scuola dove dicevano che tutto
andava bene a dir la verità quello che
ho trovato nella mia seconda scuola fu
qualcosa di incredibile forse se
aspettando che io dovevo veramente
decidere di andar via
eppure ci pu ragazzo in quel viale che
mi disse ma è vero che ti hanno
trasferita e devi arrivare nella scuola
superiore e dico pare di sì e se tu ci
sei io vengo ecco la frase mi accompagna
tutti i giorni ho ricominciato a
togliere quello che gli altri avevano
lasciato ho continuato ad ordinare ho
tirato brilla bellezza di quella scuola
non soltanto in termini fisici ma in
termini di vita sento dentro di me una
forza incredibile quando incrocio agli
occhi dei genitori
loro sono impotenti non ce l'hanno
quella non hanno vissuto non hanno
potuto godere di quella conoscenza
allora sono io lì che devo fare da ponte
e questo ponte cerco di costruirlo nella
mia mente tutti i giorni accogliendo i
ragazzi facendo capire che quei ragazzi
hanno aspettato troppo quell'agenda
aspettato troppo
e allora io devo fare qualcosa di più
devo rendere sempre impeccabile tutto
quello che accade della scuola
devo randy impeccabile lo strumento
didattico devo tornare il libro più del
pc
devo donare sguardi più di un pc
devo aprire le braccia e mi auguro che
esperte presto riaprire le scuole perché
nella mia realtà chiudere una scuola
significa uccidere due volte in questo
momento mi sento in prigione
eppure ho trovato un modo come
contattare i miei ragazzi nel periodo di
marzo
ho aperto un filo diretto che mi
scriverà 500 ragazzi mi hanno scritto
notte giorno la frase che porto dentro
di me a scuola mi sentivo protetto
allora ho fatto di più ogni giorno ho
aperto la scuola la luce sempre accesa
quel pochino che ho potuto fare è
servito è servito a non perdere i miei
ragazzi io ho un sogno o un sogno di
realizzare un ponte un ponte fisico tra
la scuola e quella piazza che tutti
ricordano come la peggiore d'europa in
quella piazza ci dobbiamo arrivare noi
con la nostra conoscenza e non dobbiamo
aver paura
io ho paura di chi ha paura io ho paura
dell'indifferenza io non ho paura dei
ragazzi io non ho paura di quella gente
che ha bisogno della di quella
conoscenza che le ho avuto la gioia di
di esercitare se io so di più devo
donare perché quella energia che c'è in
quel luogo è troppo grande e un secondo
sogno è quello di far godere a tutta
l'italia della bravura dei miei ragazzi
della forza di questi ragazzi perché
loro devono veramente superare tante
problematiche e tante tentazioni prima
di arrivare nel cancello della scuola e
io devo far vivere esperienze positive
devono andare fuori contaminare il
territorio e un giorno di raimondo dirà
il territorio grazie non a me
io non devo vincere questa battaglia
oggi io devo immaginare che l'altro
possa godere
di quanto fatto
ecco io dico grazie a voi e dico grazie
ai miei ragazzi perché posso raccontare
la mia esperienza solo grazie a loro
voi non immaginate che cosa c'è in quel
luogo cioè il ragazzino che non è mai
stato ragazzino c'è l'adulto perché lui
assorbe tutto quello che vive lo
trasmette a scuola e sia della scuola
che deve regolare quei momenti brutti
non dobbiamo avere preoccupazione di
arrivare in un luogo soltanto perché non
abbiamo il lavoro quello di vanno scelti
quanto di danno tu non lo sai
il cambiamento che vuoi vedere nel mondo
e lo diceva un grande e vero io l'ho
proprio tutti i giorni
io dico che grazie a loro io posso dare
di più
grazie allora abbiamo la possibilità di
riaprire riaccendere i motori quei
motori importanti quello che quello del
pensiero
dobbiamo smettere di dire ai ragazzi
utilizza questo oggetto
no io voglio dire ai ragazzi cosa vuoi
fare tu io voglio che i ragazzi
ricominciano a da prepararsi del
pensiero e spero presto che qualcuno
debba un luogo dare più ascolto al mondo
della scuola in questo momento
particolare
siamo tutti presi da questi sogni
tecnologici noi non possiamo chiamarci
persone se non ci formiamo ci formiamo
guardando nell'occhio l'altro può essere
tutto perfetto il computer tutto
corregge ma la bellezza della vita e
nella diversità anche nel tono della
voce e tutti possiamo liberarci a questo
momento è un piano b la didattica a
distanza
ma noi teniamo il piano ha da difendere
noi dobbiamo fare in modo che il medico
futura debba godere della forza della
scuola la sanità non ha senso quella del
domani
se oggi noi chiudiamo i cancelli la
giustizia non può oggi immaginarsi di
vivere chiudendo un palazzo anche
accendere tutte le luci tutti i giorni e
un segnale per tutti che noi ci siamo e
ci dobbiamo essere per sempre